you know i had fulio up here about a
month ago i don't know if you saw the
interview
um but i you know i'd asked him you know
if he'd ever be open to talking to you
and and try
i mean and i i'm not a i'm not anybody
to tell anybody how to
behave when life is lost you know what
i'm saying
at the same time and by the way i
you know i i held him on over the fire
about the record he put out
his response to your record because i
thought that that was not the
very low low class move to do what he
did you know what i'm saying
um but what what it like is there
any sort of line in the sand that's like
that that is even
they that when it comes to this [ __ ]
anymore because y'all really
man between who i smoke and the response
it seems like all bets are off and i've
i mean i grew up listening to tupac do
hit him up and [ __ ] wasn't even as crazy
as what y'all are
talking about bro i don't really know
is there is there any like would you
ever be open to having a discussion
like you know what i'm saying like i
ain't really
i don't know him like i've never seen
that before right never i don't even
know
you guys have never had any any
discussion no talks nothing i've never
seen
none of these people before it's like i
say people see bad they want this to see
the bad bro
what is the thing is like you're going
to keep on performing who i smoke
because it's one of the hardest hardest
songs in the man i'm getting worse
you're getting paid to do the shows it's
getting played in clubs
and he's and he's getting the biggest
eyes he's ever seen off of this [ __ ]
that he put out
and it's like there's what's the
incentive to stop the
the the the violence you know what i'm
saying or even just i don't know man i
mean i just feel like i'd be
irresponsible to see you up here and
and not and not bring it up to you know
what i'm saying i don't know dude
forever like i ain't gonna lie to you
i don't know him at all never seen him
before in life
never we never even seen each other
never seen none of them i don't never
see none of them nobody no they don't
even know me so that's why i say like
i ain't needing like you feel me i gotta
say brothers
i'm turning money like i ain't i'm to
the money